They'll shaft writer Aquarius.
Well,
actually the first time,
you know,
I was always a funny and my family is
funny.
I'm the fifth of six children from the
large Jewish family.
That was,
it was never enough guilt to go around.
And um,
when I was 18 I was at deerfield academy
and uh,
me and a few of my friends,
we might have stolen a faculty member's
car and we drove into North Hampton and
I did seven minutes of standup,
mostly stolen material at a bar called
the early times and from the ages of 18
to 22,
I think I probably performed twice a
year.
I wanted my undergraduate talent show
at,
at Harvard doing stand up.
And it was always something I knew I
could do.
It was always like a hobby with me,
but I always had the feeling that if the
nut came to crunch a,
I could make a little money at it.
But I majored.
I majored in Latin at Harvard because I
thought the church was going to come
back.
And um,
you know,
it's one of those things where I majored
in Latin and Greek because I loved,
that was the only thing I really was
interested in academically.
It really,
I think it's the best preparation for a
writer because it teaches you the value
of a word and of the word.
And um,
so I went to Harvard fully intending to
be either,
you know,
a Latin teacher or a pharmacist,
I mean really,
really,
what can you do with a classics degree?
And I'm a,
I ended up,
I think I got a c minus in.
I'm in a graduate course my freshman
year in Hurghada this.
And then I turned my sites to becoming a
sports writer.
And uh,
I did that for awhile and then I became,
I was a standup comic for 13 years.
And then in 1991 I was hired,
uh,
by then late night with David Letterman
at NBC and,
and here we are
when you're 16,
17,
18,
and you're staying up and you're
watching the tonight show.
And this is,
this is the mid,
the early and mid seventies,
you know,
it's,
it's George Carlin and Richard Pryor.
And,
and I was introduced to Lenny Bruce when
I was 18,
so huge influence on not my standup but
me wanting to become a standup and I was
just one of those guys that I would
watch the standups and boy,
that must be great to do that.
But you know,
you never think that that's what you're
gonna do.
And,
and I ended up doing it for,
for,
for 13 years.
And uh,
I heard,
I don't know who's this line has,
but it's a great line,
is that people become standup comics.
Uh,
the same way a woman becomes a hooker.
I mean,
you start,
uh,
doing it,
um,
for,
uh,
a couple of friends and then you realize
you're good enough to get paid.
When I was a comedian and I was a comic
for 13 years,
my act was Jews sports and whether that
was pretty active.
Talk about being Jewish.
I did a lot of sports material because I
was a sports writer and uh,
and I also had a Gig a later on I was,
I had my own humor column in sports
illustrated for three years called the
show,
which I love,
which was the perfect marriage of all my
careers.
It was just topical jokes about sports
every week and um,
and,
and I was a,
I'm going to steal David Letterman's
line about his standup career.
I was good.
I was a good standup,
but I was never going to be the guy that
you pay $20 to see.
I was just not going to because because
unlike my wife who still performs my
heart wasn't in it.
I didn't have to be up there.
I was good enough to be up there.
I made a living at it.
But boy,
I'll tell Ya,
you know,
12 years in and you wake up in,
in a motel six in Covington,
Kentucky,
and you say to yourself,
I'm not in show business.
I'm just willy Loman with a bag of
jokes.
I'm just going from town to town trying
to,
you know,
trying to get the people in in a
different town and that's,
that's all it was.
But I was,
you know,
I was one of those guys that was out
there and I did every television show
except the ones that could help your
career.
It was so funny because they knew me at
the letterman show,
not as a writer because I used to
audition to try and get on the show as a
comic.
And I had a line in my act,
uh,
which has been a,
I'm proud to say has been stolen by
several comics at a line in my act.
I said,
for those of you here in New York,
it's great.
The dyslexic theater company is in town
and they're doing.
He gets your nug and Bob Martin,
the producer,
Letterman,
said,
if you have six more minutes as good as
that one line,
he said,
I will put you on next week.
And sadly I did.
I had some good lines.
I've forgotten them all.
I,
um,
you know,
a couple of years ago I wrote for Chris
Rock on the Academy Awards and he hired
a lot of comics to right,
and it was a lot of people I hadn't seen
a long time because I stopped performing
and Carol Liefer was one of the writers
and Carol for and we went out the first
night we went out for Chinese food and
Carolee for said,
you know,
every time I have Chinese food I think
about your bit about Chinese food.
And I said to her,
I'd love to hear it because I have no
recollection of this.
And the bit was I used to do a bit
about,
um,
you know,
when you go out for Chinese food,
they take down your order in Chinese,
the waiter,
how are you supposed to dispute this
bill at the end of the meals?
He gives me a waiter.
I didn't order the television antenna
and that's the kind of cutting edge
stuff that came out of me.
First of all.
Thank you.
Uh,
I'm,
I'm glad that the question is phrased so
that it's assumed that I write funny
stuff every day.
I appreciate that,
you know,
I think if you do it and if you,
if you write for a strip show,
which is what Letterman is,
which is a show that's on five days a
week,
um,
you don't think about it in terms of if
you ever,
if I ever thought about what I had to do
at the beginning of every day,
I don't think I could do it.
It's just with comedy writing,
especially writing on a daily basis.
It's a muscle that you work and it's,
it's,
you know,
and if you keep working it,
you can do it.
And Woody Allen once said about joke
writing,
if you can do it,
there's nothing to it.
And I believe that and I'm mostly with
the letterman show.
I've been a monologue writer,
so the,
I just write jokes for the most part.
I work on other stuff on the show and
it's just when I first started the show
in 1991 and they told me I had to write
15 jokes a day.
I thought,
how am I going to do this?
And then I just tried to get through
that day.
And then within about six months I was,
I wasn't writing 15 jokes a day,
I was writing 25 or 30 and it got to the
point where I was writing like 50 or 60
jokes a day and you know,
they're not all great and actually very
few of them are great.
But that's the thing about comedy is
that you have to,
you have to write a lot to get,
you have to make mounds and mounds of
Cole slaw to get one good serving.
And that's what we do on the letterman
show.
We just create a lot of content and
ideally the best content gets on the
show.
Here's the thing about the late show
with David Letterman,
the writers and Dave letter.
We write a lot of stuff that's funny.
We read a lot of stuff.
It's pretty good.
We read a lot of stuff that's lame,
but invariably,
invariably night after night,
the funniest moments in this show are
dave reacting in real time to his
surroundings.
And it's something that you cannot write
in preparation for the show.
And Dave comes out at the beginning of
the night,
the writer's job is to put him in a
situation where if he needs it,
it's there,
you know,
the monologue is there.
If he needs it,
the top 10 is there.
If he needs a couple of good tape pieces
are there,
if he needs it,
and then he can just relax and just
react in the moment.
And uh,
you know,
I have a friend,
Kelly Rogers,
who I started with who was a great comic
that people don't know about and Kelly
Rogers said something that was so
profound.
He said,
your act is for the nights when you're
not funny.
And,
and that's,
that's the,
that's what the writer's supply to Dave,
they supply him enact for those nights
when,
when he doesn't feel funny.
And,
and I have yet to see a nightlight that
Larry and I used to talk about this all
the time at the beginning of the show
because originally they got picked up
for four episodes and he would say just
enough for the four shows that we're
doing.
But after that they pick the show up.
I don't remember what am I supposed to
do?
And I said,
uh,
Larry,
it's eight in the morning.
I just woke up please.
But it's one of those things where the
longer you do it,
the more things occur to you.
And of course now Larry,
David having worried about that.
Okay,
let me start that again.
And now Larry David having worried about
that at the beginning,
he figured out a way throughout the
years to incorporate his life into his
work and you know,
how you know,
how you're out at dinner with friends
and somebody says something or something
happens and somebody at the dinner table
says,
this is just like an episode of Seinfeld
a,
okay?
That may or may not be true,
but when you're with Larry David,
you never know when a,
you know,
a scene from curb your enthusiasm is
going to burst out.
And I'll just give you an example.
A couple of years ago,
uh,
Larry and I were having dinner and,
we got to the end of the meal and I said
to him,
how about some dessert?
And he said to me,
no,
no dessert for me.
Ted Danson and I have a bet,
no dessert for a year.
And I thought,
who?
It's Larry David,
it's Ted Danson.
They're both billionaires.
The bed is no dessert for a year.
I mean,
the bed has got to be at least $50,000,
maybe 100,000,
maybe.
It's a million dollars.
I said to him,
how much is the bed for?
He says,
$200.
I said,
have a piece of frigging cake.
Let me just say this about Larry David a
try as he might to distance himself from
the character that the world sees,
he will be unsuccessful at that because
I,
I know this guy,
you know,
there's a great expression,
a alcoholics are just like everybody
else except more so.
And uh,
Larry David is just like the guy you see
in curb your enthusiasm except more so
he has,
um,
again,
and I wish this was my line,
but somebody once said about famous
people,
um,
when they get famous they don't get
better.
And Larry David is the exception to that
because Larry,
as he has gotten better known,
is much more comfortable in his skin and
he used to be and much more self aware.
And I'll give you an example.
We were at a Yankee game,
uh,
last year and a kid comes up,
you know,
18,
19 years old,
comes up with a pen and paper and his
is,
uh,
you know,
a Mr David can,
can I get short of graph?
And he and Larry says to them,
oh,
come back after the [inaudible] this is
no good either in the middle of a game.
And the kid says,
well,
I can always just come back in the,
in the,
you know,
after the inexact I'm watching the game.
And,
and the kid says,
uh,
but,
but you don't understand it,
let us know.
And then hearing himself do that,
he burst out laughing and sign the kid's
paper.
So like I have to tell you,
15 years ago,
that does not happen.
That does not 15 years ago,
uh,
this whole scenario winds up in small
claims court.
I've been at the letterman show since
1991 and that's 18 years and I would say
during that time the comedic sensibility
of the show has changed,
I want to say half a dozen times because
Dave has gotten older,
but the average age of the average
writer has stayed the same.
So they bring in their sensibilities and
what they think is fun and they try and
interject it into the show.
And so the show's comedic sensibility,
uh,
changes and it's,
it's all valid and we don't write
anything and think,
oh,
I need to write this joke to appeal to
the crucial male,
18 to 34 demographic.
We don't think like that.
At least I don't.
I just think what's the funniest take
that,
that I can do.
And sometimes,
uh,
I think that things have passed me by
just because I'm older and the people
watching are our younger sometimes I
think that.
But funny is funny is funny.
And,
uh,
if you show somebody,
a Marx brothers movie who's never seen
one,
I think that they'll think it's funny
and I don't think that they're going to
ask why isn't groucho naked?
You know,
I want to see Groucho's deal
late night has really changed in the
last,
um,
I think in the last three decades,
let's say.
I think that first of all,
there's more variety and there's more
competition.
You know,
before 1982,
there was johnny and Johnny Carson and
people that he knocked off.
So all of late night was just,
was carson and it was a monologue.
It was some sort of body broad comedy
aimed at people over 30,
clearly,
um,
and uh,
white people over and white men over
over 30.
And um,
so that was it.
And then Dave came along in 1982 and NBC
gave Dave Letterman one directive,
uh,
whatever you do,
we want it not to be the tonight show.
So we want a three joke monologue,
not a 25 joke monologue a we want,
you know,
we just don't want it to look like the
tonight show.
So,
given that,
go ahead,
it was very free flowing.
It was irony based,
uh,
and it was a,
the old producer,
Bob Moore used to say a late night with
David Letterman.
It celebrated failure.
It was not slick.
It was very,
uh,
anarchistic.
And um,
so that was so,
so then that comes along.
Then,
uh,
you have dave move into cbs 1130 and you
have this situation with Jay where,
uh,
you had a one show,
that was a host driven,
which is Dave and,
and,
uh,
material driven.
I'm more,
I would say more concept driven.
And then he had another show which is
Jay who was just essentially just a
comic who got his own show and its
monologue and guests and a little more,
uh,
a traditional.
And then you had the 1230 shows with
Conan and all of a sudden they were.
David started this with going after
younger audiences.
I mean,
people always say,
I started watching Dave and college and
uh,
so there was a real market out there.
And then,
like I mentioned before,
late night became this very lucrative,
um,
uh,
industry for the networks,
very cheap to produce very,
and course once a commercialism,
once people start making money,
it's going to tend to get watered down
and it's not gonna be as a,
it's not going to be as fearless,
um,
because there's a lot of people that
depend their livelihoods depend on your
success,
so it's not just kids screwing around
anymore.
And then what happened in,
I would say the late nineties,
uh,
is that the other,
the cable emerge as a late night force
with the daily show and Kobe Bayer and
it was much more topical,
not that the Letterman show we always
took care of what was in the news and so
did Jay,
but it,
it became a more of a,
the,
the topical stuff.
It became more topical and more issue
oriented.
And,
and I think we've certainly gone in that
direction at the late show.
And so that's the evolution of that now.
I think that
if I was to predict and,
and believe me,
I'm always wrong.
So put your money elsewhere.
I think we're going to reach a critical
mass with the topicality thing and
people getting their news because I
think it's going to get a little too
partisan and I think that a late night
shows are going to be put in a situation
that they shouldn't be put in a,
you know,
unbeknownst to them,
and I think it's probably going to go
back to a little sillier and,
um,
uh,
a little less a celebrity driven and,
um,
and,
and kind of easier to take and less fo
serious.
You look at a guy like Craig Ferguson
and watch what he's doing.
He,
nobody is doing what he's doing and,
and I think he'll,
I think he'll,
he will emerge because he is silly.
It's all him,
you know,
uh,
the guests don't really have to say
anything.
He's going to take care of it.
And I think that,
um,
I think that that's where we're going.
I don't think that Johnny ever dream
that he would influence a,
an election.
Um,
you know,
he,
uh,
he never talked about Watergate when
Watergate was going on and talked about
it after the fact.
Uh,
but,
uh,
you know,
Tina fey had as much to do with the last
election as a,
as Dave did with the situation with
mccain as the daily show,
a does.
So,
uh,
you know,
look where is,
I mean that's where we are,
where these shows and,
and,
and none of these shows set out to
influence elections,
but that's what happens.
They're there,
right in the popular culture.
And you know,
I never bought all those,
uh,
um,
studies and surveys about people getting
their news from late night television.
I and I still don't,
but I think that people turn to late
night television,
um,
to see what the point of view is on the
news.
I think they know going in,
I don't think we're in the education
business.
Here's the deal with society.
People Fall in love with the idea of
things rather than the reality of
things.
And that holds true for late night.
You know,
it's,
it's so much a more provocative and
sexier to say that people are watching
our show and getting their news from
Dave letterman.
And let me tell you,
as somebody that writes monologue jokes
and somebody that knows Dave,
I tell them,
you,
we find that very funny.
Here's the difference between a writing
a monologue jokes in writing a fiction,
uh,
well,
first of all,
use the word intern much less and
waterboarding much less when you write
fiction.
No,
it,
it's,
it's just,
it's a different muscle.
A writing a monologue jokes or writing
jokes for a nightly show is a volume
business.
It's a volume business.
You're just turning out a quantity and
then panning for gold.
So it's,
you're using,
uh,
in,
in the words of the steroid universe,
you're using your quick twitch muscles.
You know,
you're just firing more,
you're firing quicker and you're just
reacting quicker.
And it's all about,
takes different,
how many different takes to a premise.
So that's,
that's writing comedy for television.
Now,
writing a fiction,
writing humorous fiction,
everything slows down and it's a
different muscle and it's a state of
mind.
And uh,
you know,
I think writing jokes is,
is a real physical practice.
And um,
and it's all free association and,
and writing fiction.
Again,
it's inhabiting a,
it's getting into a state of mind where
you're a for me,
where you're inhabiting this world of
these characters you created.
And for me,
writing fiction,
you know,
I want to be funny.
I want my premises to be funny.
I want my situations to be funny.
I want my characters to be complicated,
but it must be plausible.
It must be even however chaotic.
It must be plausible.
And the thing about a lot of great
monologue jokes is that they are not
plausible.
There's sort of a little really,
you know,
it's like when we talked about this,
people ask me,
how'd you learn to write fiction?
Well,
I learned to write fiction writing for
Dave because,
uh,
you know,
all of a sudden we'd have some jokes
about Hillary Clinton and Dave would
say,
let's just start it with,
hey,
have you heard Hillary Clinton's going
to jail?
Well,
she's not.
She never was,
but he loved that it was a grabber.
He could get a laugh and then he would,
he could come down off it,
off the joke.
Now
that might find its way in somebody
else's novel,
but it's never going to find its way in
a minute.
I'll give you an example.
When Hillary was elected to the Senate,
um,
and,
and then bill was out of office.
There was a story in the times that he
was a little lonely in Chappaqua.
He was sort of rattling around the
house,
so he would go down once a week and have
breakfast at a coffee shop in Chappaqua.
And that's kind of quaint.
It's kind of charming.
Well,
that,
that wasn't good enough for us.
That was,
that we didn't like that,
that wasn't good comedically.
So we did jokes for two weeks about him
hanging out at a singles bar in
Chappaqua.
We just made up all these and it was
great and we had a ball with it.
And,
and it is it.
Well,
I guess I'm sort of arguing against
myself because it is a little plausible.
The Clinton might go to a singles bar,
but we just made it up and um,
and people knew we had made it up and it
was,
it was very valid as,
as a,
as comedy.
So that's the deal of the best advice I
ever got about writing fiction was,
um,
right.
What you know,
and make your character's lives
complicated because,
you know,
we all have a story in us and it's,
it's our autobiography.
And I know we think it's fascinating.
God knows I do and it may very well be
fascinating,
but it aint complicated.
This is my third novel.
Everything hurts and,
and it is,
um,
it is born of a real life.
This is a book about a guy trying to get
rid of a psychosomatic limp.
And he seeks the aid of a legitimate
self help guru.
He's an accidental self help guru and to
cure him of his psychosomatic limp,
he seeks the aid of a legitimate self
help guru and is borne of real life.
Because for three and a half years I
dragged a foot,
I limped,
I was in constant pain and it was a.
It confounded doctorsx,
rays and Mris,
turned up nothing.
The pain moved around.
There was no consistent symptomatology.
It came and went of its own accord.
It made no sense to anybody,
but I was in constant pain and so I
sought the help of a guy who specialized
in a psychosomatic pain.
And uh,
he believes that the pain is caused by
unconscious rage driving to your
conscious mind and your conscious mind
is so threatened by the coming rage that
it tries to distract you by giving you
pain to a vulnerable area.
That's his theory.
I still believe in it.
I really do.
And so his approach is to examine your
past.
So I'd been seeing him for a little
while and I said,
you know what I'm gonna do.
I'm going to write a novel about a guy
trying to get rid of a psychosomatic
limp and try to get myself out of this
pain.
And I started writing it.
It took me two years to finish.
Two years later,
I'm finished with the book,
son of a bitch guy in the book is fine.
I'm still dragging a foot and in
constant pain.
So I sold the book to Simon and
Schuster.
Ten days after I sold the book I went to
yet another doctor took another look at
another x ray and said to me,
you need a hip replacement.
I'm not telling you you should get one.
I'm telling you,
you have to get one.
This is a no brainer.
And so a year ago in July,
last July,
I got my hip replaced.
I'm out of pain.
I feel great.
And everybody who,
you know,
suffered along with me said,
you must be furious.
Three and a half years limping and
constant pain.
And I say the same thing,
all of them.
If I hadn't done that,
I wouldn't have gotten the book out of
it.
So,
you know,
the journey is the destination,
right?
You have no idea.
Um,
because as I,
as I mentioned,
I was in constant pain and one of the
few times that I was not in pain was
when I was writing.
And I mean writing at the letterman show
or working on the fiction,
but at the end of the day here,
the day would be over.
I'd come home and relax,
put my feet up,
incredible pain,
and they could not be relieved by any
pill or anything like that,
which made me sure it was a.
and so this book is a reflection of
that.
And,
uh,
I think that,
um,
you know,
and I'm sure people have said this
before,
but,
uh,
artists create because they have to,
not because they need to and not because
they think they should,
but because they have to.
And this is,
this was a classic case of it.
So it was very fulfilling.
It was very ambitious because I was
suffering while I was writing it and the
guy is getting better and it's like,
and I was aspiring to the character I
was writing about,
which is a boy,
I'd love to recreate that in my next
book.
Wouldn't that be great?